hi welcome back in the previous two
sections we have shown you how to
extract the information from the drive
data set into individual file space of
the cell lines now in this exercise what
we are going to do is we are going to
merge all those data into a matrix which
consists of only the data about
pancreatic cancers
okay so here is a data set that we have
extracted previously you can see that
there is individual files consist of the
data based on the cell lines now what we
are going to do is we are going to
select those cell lines and are actually
pancreatic cancers and then compile it
into a matrix format so how do we know
that which cell lines is actually from
what type of tumors in order to find out
that you can actually go back to the
supplementary figure from the paper or
the supplementary data under the
supplementary data - okay if you open it
you can see that they will give you a
range of a notation for example this is
the cell lines and this is where the
primary sites belongs and this is the
classification of the tumors by the
pathologies for example so what we want
to do here is basically we are going to
identify what are the sound lines that
are actually originated from the
pancreas or pancreatic cancer so we will
filter it by pancreas now here you will
get a list of the cells a list of this
cell lines which is considered as okay
pancreatic cancer
so once you have identified which cell
lines are belongs to the pancreatic
cancer the next thing is we are going to
use the delimit software again to
basically compile the individual file
into one single matrix so let's open the
delimit program here ok so now in this
in here basically we want to join ok all
the individual file into a single matrix
table so now so in the joint files
category we will select horizontally
because we want to join it horizontally
and then we can select what let the
cells type that we want to join so these
are the these are the individual files
so now what we need to do is basically
we need to select the cells the cell
lines that are pancreatic cancer for
example okay px pc3 it's one of it and
then we also have CF pack one for
example you can go down the list and
then continue to to select all the cell
lines that is belongs to the pancreas in
this exercise here I'm just going to
show you ok how it would looks like okay
to join a few files so then you can try
it out later on with the whole dataset
so in this case I'm just going to join
ok 3000 you will see that oops sorry
you will see that ok and bxp c3 ok so
you will see that ok three files was
being selected now you can also select
ok whether you want to join all the
columns basically if you remember from
the last exercise each of the extracted
individual file actually consists of
common some of the common column for
example ok in PHP c3 if we open it up so
you will see that the first two column
is actually universal across all the
cell line so we actually do need to
include that so what I'm going to do is
basically I will ask
the dilemma software not to join the
first two columns except for the first
foul okay so that all the data from
different file will actually match it to
the individual rows and also the
variables now the limitation rules you
have to select basically comma because
when we export it out it is actually a
CSV file or call or comma delimited file
format so it will be by comma and then
without filename then you can name any
file name that you want okay in this
case here enemy has test and then after
that I just need to press the join
button so you can see the progress bar
here this is the output of how it will
looks like again you will see that the
first two column is universal across the
okay CF pack file this is message to the
dang cell lines file and this is message
to the BX PC tree files and again if you
go to the the the excel file format test
whether it is yeah you can't then
actually open it up and then you in the
excel file so once this is completed so
if you complete the whole selection of
the of the file you will actually get
something that okay look like this so
this is the one that I have done
previously basically just to show you
how it will looks like after the
compilation okay you will look at these
are all the pancreatic cancer cells in
the particular in the matrix table but
it is not and yet we still have a lot of
work to do on it so and in the next step
what we are going to do is basically to
match each of the shrna back to the gene
level
okay so now that you have the matrix
table so here what we are going to do is
we are going to match this the
individual shrna into a particular gene
so if you remember correctly the drive
project actually is shRNA library screen
and each gene was actually targeted by
multiple shRNA so in order to identify
which shRNA targeting which gene so we
have to go back to the supplementary
table again
okay audit or the raw data set where
they there's this file called shrna gene
map so if you open up the shRNA gene map
so what you will see is that okay this
is the sequence and then this is the
gene this is the gene symbol basically
and then you also have the entree ID to
refer to the to the gene ID so what we
want to do now is basically to comp out
this information okay into this matrix
table and the way to actually do it is
that we can use Excel okay there's
something what we called we look up
format so we will create a few extra
column here so we are going to copy the
heading okay from the gene map so you
have hating here now so what we are
going to do is basically now okay we
have to so we will actually match the
sequence back to the gene gene symbol
and the way to do it is that you can use
a wheel lookup function you can learn
about it from online whole this is
basically done so first we basically it
will help it would tell you is that we
look up the first value will be the
lookup value I'm going to match this
okay with the table data from here and
then return the value from column number
two which is a gene symbol and then it
must be a max exact exact match so
that's why I will put forth okay
so it's a very powerful well it is
actually a very oh sorry it is actually
a very powerful command okay in Excel
that you can actually use it from
anything now you see that that's coming
up so okay so you can actually check
whether this is correct and go back here
and then you can search the sequence
so whether okay so this is a LPP l2 so
same as here okay so you can repeat this
basically to match with the okay on
trace ID now again the lookup value will
be here the map is the same but then now
you want to return the number from
column number three and then here here
you go you will get that okay so now all
you need to do is basically you copy the
whole the whole formula through the to
the end of data set and then it will
then automatically okay match the
sequence okay here to the gene set go to
the gene symbol that is on the gene map
table okay so it takes a while and here
you go
so now it is all properly match okay now
we have the created a matrix table okay
so this is this is true so we consider
our raw the original matrix table so we
can refer to this later on if you want
to make any other changes now without
disturbing the original data I'm going
to create okay and not basically create
another copy so if there's anything so
that I can always come back to this page
here okay
let the original matrix table that we
have created so I would create a copy of
this into a different into a separate
excel sheet okay so it would take a
while because the file is quite big
alright and here you go
so I would I name this as always you
know and then this would be
but it's a step that we need to do next
is basically now is to remove some of
the sequins that do not match to any of
the jeans so now you will notice that
okay if we filter it by gene symbol
basically you will see that okay there
are some they are actually some jeans
which is actually not mesh to the
sequins
so you can see that some of this light
does okay
zero-zero these are basically some of
the control SH RNA that they you so what
we are going to do is we are going to
remove this because in the following
step so the system would not be able to
recognize this gene symbol okay so we
are going to remove all this data okay
just basically by deleting it okay again
it will take some time because the data
set is quite huge
you
okay once you finish doing that there's
a few more things that we can do to
clean it up for example okay like the
column on experiment and pool well this
information is basically not required
for our analysis we can actually delete
those column so that we would know that
okay to basically make the make the size
of the file smaller and also much easier
for you to do the downstream analysis
you can do this for each of the cell
lines in the matrix file no the
important thing that I want to show you
is basically now there are some cell
lines which do not have a complete data
set okay for example okay I can show you
is that even in the paper it did
mentioned that okay some of the cell
lines the control was actually quite low
now like for example this one here the
Mya Parker to the plasma is a control
this is after the incubation period and
you can see that the control actually
somehow there's a technical failure in
in the experiment so and the way they
you
so after some of the clean up so that
they - it looks like this basically each
of the columns you have two columns here
the plasma country and also the sample
account and then